hello and welcome to video pain oops my
voice yeah so let's see if I can get
some writing points back I lost the last
game due to add you to the doorbell
ringing that was bad I had to scratch
that recording it was a completely
unclear position and then and then I got
someone at the door I still have some
issue with the doorbell here it's a bit
difficult to explain but it's a bit
tricky well it's actually not difficult
to explain the doorbell is working but
um I'm living on the first first floor
and there is this I'm ever have a phone
basically I can we can speak to the
person knows who's at the door and this
this phone is not working so it's a bit
difficult sometimes because you might
have someone coming up that you wouldn't
have even learned that in in the first
place if you would have known who it was
and yeah this is what happened so I had
someone at the door that it took ages to
get rid of and while I was talking to
telling this story I played into this is
this line here which I actually had I
wanted to abandon yeah but I was in on
some kind of autopilot mode and played
it anyway this old chigorin line where
I'm constantly gal suffering a little
bit
yeah I have actually arrived I don't
want to play that anymore but it was out
of routine iam I played it again yeah
I'm just out for UK 8 they're only big
advantage with this opening is that I've
played it so often that I don't need to
spend much time this is helpful yeah and
if Blaque this is my experience from as
I said a million sit close to of blitz
games if Black gets to trade down on the
a file nothing bad happens to him
usually okay it should be six it's not
clear that i want that only dad think it
does work though I mean in general it's
desirable for me to trade that but I
wasn't completely sure about the
specifics of this position but I think
it's all right
okay now I get in Luke a six and even
get to trade the last heavy pieces and
then I'm definitely okay in fact I have
won lots of endings of that time
ultimately by plane the move f5 it's got
many pieces positioned to prevent it if
he gets the night 33 so f is very tough
to play but I still have a second option
let's see if I can get that going one
night to do six one night only seven and
then combine f5 with the idea where P
sacrifice on d5 it's probably 22 closed
to get going
but we'll see sometimes white yeah this
is I'm not sure that's ambitious I'm
invading with the King now wyd
absolutely has nothing here they're
being being ambitious can backfire quite
badly this already um yeah wasn't any
good to be honest and what what he what
you went for here ok so i can go f5 here
or i can already sacrifice on d5 which
is however not clear that it helps okay
i'll go fi the problem is that this pawn
on d5 becomes vulnerable back we cannot
easily take okay empty chance now and
stick here
ok it's got d4 available
it's definitely difficult to difficult
appeal win with black it's probably
probably equal was that some zoosk one
maybe that I can play for hmm ok the f4
night cannot the e 2 nite cannot move
the f1 night is able to move even though
it's not clear that it wants to maybe I
can improve my night here and I'm not
quite sure okay so maybe I should have
gotten a day for actually not sure check
and I probably cannot do much in
I thought I can maybe do something on
the d5 pawn but it simply doesn't work
there's until d to anything check I hope
I'm not playing it to ambitiously my
deaf 5mm doesn't doesn't really do much
check ok
sometimes white can sacrifice on c4 but
check it shouldn't work in this position
okay I don't know it's probably a draw
anyway check time morning to check check
yeah what about this can I construct
some kind of suits long here probably
not yeah I can do nothing here again
let's offer a drop game ah it's nothing
nothing possible I thought I'd get
somewhere after you played h5 which was
completely unnecessary giving me this
but probably instead wrong check o king
of six is the key ok now that's a that's
bad that I didn't see that I mean I felt
I should have something and kind of
wondered why no nothing materialized
this is why I can't go after what this I
have to take have to go back oh now it's
a it's a big difference okay this is now
completely bad check so and if white
takes layer then I mean in very good
shape both should be good actually exist
check check is this is still a draw
though the night IAM yeah okay so i
cannot i mean that that doesn't lead to
much have to do this probably now that's
better now that that would be a pawn
will just be upon i will take e 40 85
next so he has to avoid any caption now
it has to keep the tension with a move
like this very interesting the engine
wants to play this now probably because
this is losing King d2 and now it wants
to take twice and go here nahi black has
winning chances clearly yeah then um I'm
a bit sorry for playing this line again
I really yeah i really had discounted
that that I don't want to play but it's
sometimes like if you don't think
actively like I didn't do here I was
telling my doorbell story I was just
playing this without thinking much but
okay why does playing it dead and
ambitiously like he did black has no
problems whatsoever but he also has a
position with the Knights here where f5
is very difficult to play and even the
only the only moment where something
happened was when he without any
particular reason played age five and
gave me that invasion idea okay well
thanks for watching